"Adding oil to pasta water
prevents the noodles from sticking."
This is definitely not true.
Hi, I'm Catherine DeOrio.
I'm a formally trained chef;
I trained here in Chicago
at Kendall College.
Worked at various restaurants,
staging in Chicago,
and I am here to debunk the
most common myths about cooking.
We're doing this via Skype,
because, like many of you,
I am stuck in my house as well,
and I know all of you will
want some tips on how to cook
while you're indoors and
trying to find things to do.
"Only flip your steak
once during cooking."
This is absolutely not true.
A lot of people say that because
where all your flavor
comes is from the browning,
so people feel that if
you're flipping your steak,
you're not gonna get a proper brown
and then all of that flavor.
But the most important
thing for a good steak
is actually the temperature of your pan.
You make sure you get it really hot,
and you can actually
flip it multiple times.
So, if you flip it about every 30 seconds,
it's going to not cool down on the top,
so it will continue to
cook, you'll flip it,
it will cook, and then it's almost like
being cooked simultaneously on both sides,
so you're actually gonna get
a faster cooking time on it,
and it will consistently cook
from edge to edge of the steak.
"Adding vinegar to your cooking water
makes your hard-boiled
eggs easier to peel."
That's not exactly true.
It's kind of a placebo effect.
So, a few things.
The age of your egg is gonna affect
how easy it is to peel.
So, an older egg is more alkaline.
That's gonna make it a
little easier to peel
after it's boiled.
The next thing is, it's really important,
is to stop that cooking right away
and submerge it in an ice bath.
So, nothing fancy, just a bowl of water
with a bunch of ice in it, nice and cold,
submerge it in it, let the cooking stop,
and then pull them out.
The other way you could get the shell
to not stick is by steaming them.
So, what happens when you steam the egg
is the proteins from your egg whites
are gonna separate from the
membrane from the shell.
It's gonna give you a little bit of space,
therefore making it easy
to peel when you're done.
"Wear goggles, chew gum, etc.,"
all of the myths you've heard to avoid
your eyes from getting watery
when you're cutting onions.
Um,
no.
So, I guess you could wear goggles,
aside from making you look very strange,
but the reason our eyes water
when we cut an onion is
there is an enzymatic reaction,
and the gases come up from the onion,
and that's actually
what gets into our eyes.
It causes them to burn, and
it causes them to water.
So, interestingly, that gas comes out
because it's a defense
mechanism for the onion
so little critters underground,
as it's growing, don't eat it.
The best way to really
mitigate the gases coming out
is to use a really sharp knife.
So, if you use a dull knife,
you're crushing the membrane of the onion,
and it's gonna cause more gas to release.
If you cut it really,
just with a really sharp knife
and you slice through it,
it's going to damage
less of the membranes,
and so less gas is gonna come up,
so it's gonna be a little easier.
Also, cut the root last.
A lot of gas is kind of
concentrated in that area,
so kind of that little
hairy part at the end,
so to speak, always cut that off last.
"Whipped cream flattens
when you stop whipping it."
So, that's not true.
It's not the whipping that will
keep the air in your cream,
which makes it fluffy, it's
actually your temperature.
So, again, temperature
is really important.
If it gets warm, that's
when your whipped cream
starts to flatten.
So the tip is,
before you whip it,
don't only chill your cream, which,
obviously you wanna get
that as cold as possible,
but I like to put my bowl and my whisk
or whisk attachment in the freezer,
get it really cold,
so when you whip it then it stays cold,
it won't flatten during
the whipping process,
and then when you're done,
you can store it in the fridge.
If you're going to go to a party,
let's just say you make a cake,
and you frost it with a cream
and there's a whipped cream element to it,
you could stick it in the
freezer for about 30 minutes.
It will make it a little more stable
if you're, for instance,
taking it to a picnic
or somewhere where
you're gonna be outside,
it's gonna be a little warm.
That will help to keep the whipped cream
nice and airy and fluffy.
"Adding oil to pasta water prevents
the noodles from sticking."
This is definitely not true.
As an Italian, this is just the one thing
that just really irks me.
So, if you put oil on your noodles,
it's actually gonna make the surface
of the noodles impenetrable to your sauce.
So, the thing that's gonna
give your noodles flavor
is not gonna be able to get in
and actually flavor them
or stick to your noodles.
So, that's kind of not
what you want, right?
Pasta is, even, like, in Italy,
the shapes of the pasta are designed
to hold certain kinds
of sauces a certain way.
So the last thing you want is, you know,
these slick noodles where all
of your sauce is coming out.
So the best way to get
noodles to stop from sticking
is, again, add your
pasta to boiling water,
make sure it's a full, rolling boil,
and then stir it every once in a while.
Make sure that you're continually stirring
that pasta as it's cooking.
This is gonna keep it
from sticking together
during the cooking process.
"You can season food at any time
during the cooking process."
No, no, no, no, no. [laughs]
Season as you go.
So, if you just season at the end,
all you're gonna have is kind of a
superficial seasoning.
There's gonna be,
the top layer of your food
is gonna have some flavor to it,
but it's not gonna have actually
penetrated your food and give you
that kind of consistent flavor throughout
and that depth and complexity,
which is what you really love.
And so that's why a lot of times
you'll make something at home
and you'll just kind
of at the end be like,
oh, season to taste, and just throw some
salt and pepper on it, maybe some herbs,
and you're like, "Why didn't this turn out
the way it tastes at a restaurant?
It's a simple dish."
But it's because you are
constantly seasoning as you go.
"Milk makes fluffier scrambled eggs."
No, no, no.
So, scrambled eggs,
it's about temperature.
It's about, think slow and low.
So you want low, medium heat,
and you wanna just cook those eggs slow,
and just once they start to coagulate,
take a spatula and move it around
so you'll keep getting those curds.
If you add milk to it,
that milk is gonna
separate out from the eggs
as it's cooking, and you're gonna probably
get rubbery, colorless,
a diluted flavor on your actual eggs.
So, slow and low.
Also, before, kind of almost right before
your eggs seem totally cooked,
so they're not runny anymore
but they seem a little wet, take them off.
There is gonna be some carryover cooking,
and they're gonna cook a
little bit more in that pan
as you're transferring
them to your serving dish.
"Sticking a potato in an overly salty dish
will absorb the salt
and make it less salty."
No. Again, no.
So, yes, will putting a raw potato
into an overly salted soup
absorb some of that salt?
Yes, but it's also gonna absorb
a disproportionate amount of the liquid,
so you don't want to do that.
The first thing you
should try before anything
is try to balance out the flavors.
So if it's saltier,
maybe just a hit of acid,
so a little dash of sherry vinegar
or a little bit of a squeeze of lemon
might balance it out, a hit of sugar.
So, just kind of think.
What makes something, a dish, taste good
is that balance, that
sweet and salty and spicy.
So just see what it might need.
Try that first.
If it doesn't work, move on.
So, "storing bread in the
fridge prevents staleness."
Actually, storing bread in the fridge
will make your bread go stale quicker.
So, it's gonna pull some
of that moisture out.
But there are ways that
you can keep your bread
for a bit longer.
So, one, you can freeze it.
Wrap it in plastic and then freeze it
and then defrost it at room temperature,
and your bread will pretty much stay
close to what it was when you bought it.
Now, if the bread's already gone stale,
is there anything you can do?
So, yes, there's a few things.
If it's already gone stale,
one, just heating the bread a little bit
will actually soften it up.
Also, you can put that
bread in the fridge.
Now, when you take it out of the fridge,
it's not that it's gonna
be back to its original state,
but it will just keep it edible
for a little bit longer.
It will keep it from
going bad or going moldy.
"Keeping a pit in your avocado
keeps the avocado from browning."
Again, no, this is not accurate.
It will keep the avocado
underneath the pit from browning.
So, the browning process happens,
it's an enzymatic reaction that causes
the flesh of the fruit to brown.
The best way for a full avocado
is to either swipe some lemon juice on it
or some type of acidulated water.
Acidulated water is basically just water
that has some acid in it.
You could also do a swipe of olive oil.
That will keep it for a little while,
'cause again that's gonna
create a seal on the top.
"Cooking with frozen
vegetables doesn't provide
the same nutrients and
flavor as fresh vegetables."
Absolutely wrong. In fact,
in some cases you'll find
that it is better to
buy frozen vegetables.
Companies out there that obviously
this is what they specialize in.
So, Birds Eye, for instance,
makes a variety of frozen vegetables,
and they flash-freeze them
so they're basically
frozen instantaneously,
right after they're picked,
so that is going to keep
all of the nutrients intact,
their flavor, and this is
at their peak ripeness,
so this is, like, the
best time you can get it.
The other thing is, vegetables do start
to degrade in their
nutrient content over time.
Right, that's, nobody's
gonna argue with that.
So there is quite a time, often,
between when it's picked
and then when it's actually shipped
and then when it's shelved
into your grocery store.
So you do have to remember,
even a thing that seems fresh
has had a bit of a life
before it got to you.
"Fresh tomatoes are better
than canned tomatoes to cook with."
One of my things that I
always have in my pantry
are canned tomatoes,
and the reason being is,
so, OK, I love fresh tomatoes.
It's, you know, late summer,
and you get that beautiful garden tomato,
and you can literally eat
it like an apple, right?
That season is about this long.
Hunt's tomato takes the tomatoes,
they can them at peak ripeness,
so it's at tomato season,
when they are their most flavorful,
and then they,
well, you basically
make them shelf stable.
So when I open that can,
they actually are from exactly
the season when you would
want to eat a tomato,
so they're gonna be kind of the sweetest,
have the most complex flavor.
So, everyone always wants to think
fresh is always better.
Fresh is great. Fresh
is great specifically
and better for some things.
Canned is way better
to have in your pantry
so that you can cook and have
very consistent good flavor
and your nutrients throughout the year.
"Microwaving robs food of its nutrients."
This is actually not true.
What will cause food
to lose some of its nutritional content
is actually just heat application,
so whether that comes from microwaving,
sautéing, baking, roasting, any boiling.
Actually, if you cook with the microwave,
in some instances, it
will actually provide
and keep more of your nutrients intact.
Now, the reason being, there's
a few things in cooking
that will cause your nutritional
content to break down.
It's a very short exposure
to heat in general.
So it's actually, in
many ways, can be argued
as a healthier way to keep
your nutritional content,
your vegetable, to cook your vegetables
and to keep the
nutritional content intact.